before there was soil or sky or any
green thing there was only the gaping
abyss of gonnago gap this darkness lay
between the homeland of elemental fire
Muspelheim and the homeland of elemental
ice nymph hime the flames from
Muspelheim and the frost from nil fire
moved ever closer and they eventually
met in the abyss as the ice began to
melt the droplets themselves formed
Ahmir the first of the giant kind email
was capable of reproducing asexually and
as he slept the sweat from underneath
his arms formed two more Giants a third
was later born creating the first family
of giants known as the yo teens from the
ice emerged a cow named our doom blur
her milk would nourish Ameer and the
other giants and in return the cow would
be nourished by the blocks of ice our
dimness licks uncovered bori the first
god of the Aesir tribe bori would have a
son called Baal who would marry Bessler
the daughter of the giant bald thorne
they later had three half God half giant
children we know them as Odin Vili and
Vey Odin and his brothers were concerned
of how quickly the Giants could
reproduce as they severely outnumbered
the Aesir the three brothers decided
that their only option was to slay Amir
and they waited to the Giants slept
before they began their assault
with all their strength the brothers
were able to overpower and slay Amir the
blood which spouted from Amir's body
formed rivers and these rivers drown all
but two giants the surviving Giants
burgled me and his wife fled to the
misty land we now know as Jotunheim the
world as we know it in Norse mythology
was created from the remains of Amir's
body Odin and his brothers dragged
Amir's body into the abyss and the nine
worlds were created his blood formed
rivers his flesh and muscles became land
vegetation was formed from his hair
clouds from his brains mountains from
his bones and his skull formed the sky
emmaus skull would cover the entire new
world and the gods placed sparks from
Muspelheim inside of the skull and these
would illuminate the world as stars they
built as God on the plains of Idaho and
this became the home of the gods
far away from Jotunheim where the Giants
were allowed to live the gods eventually
formed the first man and woman from the
trunks of to ash trees these humans were
to live in Midgard an offense was built
around them to protect them from the
Giants of Jotunheim the dwarves were
formed when a Mia's body began to rot
the worms which crawled out of the
remains became dwarves the gods became
worried that Amir's rotten body would
cause the sky to fall they sent four
dwarves one in each direction to hold up
the sky these dwarves were named after
the cardinal directions Nordy for north
soundly for south vestri for west and
austria for east the remaining dwarves
made their home on the ground and in
caves located in Swat Ohio
there was a man who had two children so
bright and luminous that he named them
Sol and Marnie the gods were angered by
the man's arrogance and so they took
both children away from him
they placed both of the children in the
sky and they would become the Sun and
Moon the Norse myth of creation is one
that has many conceptual meanings behind
it one of the most prominent being that
life comes from death the world was not
created from nothing as it was in the
judeo-christian myth rather than the
gods create in the world they first had
to slay Amir who in this case represents
the primal chaos as he can reproduce
without death or destruction
yamir's kin the Giants are constantly
attempting to drag the world back into
chaotic nothingness and during the
Ragnarok they do succeed in destroying
the world if you've enjoyed this video
then please consider leaving a thumbs up
as it helps promote the video and allows
the channel to grow if there's anything
you'd like to discuss or have any ideas
for future videos then please let me
know in the comment section as always
I've been your host mythology and
folklore explained